voilà henri antonmattei si vous voulez
nous dire un mot de cette architecture
du code du travail et est peut-être
répondre aux interpellations de bertrand
martinot sur l'explosion des lois mais
aussi de la jurisprudence et notamment
en termes de santé et de sécurité au
travail et nous dire si vous partagez
cette idée d'une lecture plus orthodoxes
de la constitution on reviendrait aux
principes généraux dans le code du
travail
alors quand on est médecin et médecins
pour soigner le droit du travail il faut
partager mesdames et messieurs le
diagnostic alors diagnostic je le
partage mais il ne faut pas non plus
sombrer dans l'excès et penser qu'on n'a
rien fait depuis plusieurs années
d'abord parce que quand vous étiez vous
une ex ump en charge les affaires vous
avez quand même fait des choses 2004
2008 2007 ce sont des lois importantes
disons les choses comme elles sont il
faudrait pas laisser penser à nos
compatriotes que nous sommes dans le mur
on n'y est pas encore en réalité le
droit du travail dans sa globalité et
vous avez bien fait de dire code du
travail plus jurisprudence plus les
règles conventionnelles
le package complet il souffre de quoi il
souffre d'une part d'une insécurité
juridique
on ne le dira jamais assez le vrai
cancer du droit c'est l'insécurité
juridique
quand un chef d'entreprise vous dit je
ne comprends pas qui plus est il y à un
aléa sur le conseil que vous me donnez
et je risque de me faire plomber
judiciairement donc quelques mois sans
avoir la possibilité de prévoir c'est le
mal absolu
le propre de la règle de droit quelle
que soit la discipline c'est d'être
prévisible
qui plus est et le conseil
constitutionnel ici est intraitable à
juste titre la règle de droit doit être
accessible et intelligible et
compréhensible donc c'est vrai que nous
avons fauté mais enfin on a tous fauté
disons les choses comme elles sont on va
se reprendre
alors comment faire nous sommes à la
croisée des chemins
et quand on est à la croisée des chemins
mesdames et messieurs qu'on se trouve en
montagne ou dans la campagne il faut
prendre le bon chemin alors certains
amènent au mur c'est exact d'autres à
des impasses alors on peut faire demi
tour
quand on est dans l'impasse et que la
capri le mur
pour regarder le bon chemin et pour
comprendre le présent et construire
l'avenir
il faut regarder le passé nous avons
fait un choix collectif
vous avez raison de le dire ce choix la
gauche le rallye qui fait que nous
avions raison
ce choix c'est quoi c'est donner un peu
plus de responsabilités aux partenaires
sociaux à la négociation collective
c'est à dire la démocratie sociale c'est
historique dans notre pays la démocratie
politique a tendu la main à la
démocratie sociale
j'ai à côté de moins représentant de la
démocratie sociale et des représentants
la démocratie politique
ça c'est signe de vitalité d'une
démocratie
lorsqu un moment donné on reconnaît
singulièrement dans le domaine des
relations de travail que des corps
intermédiaires sont capables à un moment
donné d'assumer une responsabilité et un
pouvoir normatif
simplement nous avons vous avez
représentant la démocratie politique
exigée des prérequis démocratique que
vous avez réalisé en 2004 la logique des
accords majoritaires en 2008 la nouvelle
représentativité syndicale puisque nous
avons des accords plus légitime et des
acteurs plus victimes
nous pouvons opérer une opération de
reflux législatif et c'est ce que nous
avons fait
la loi de 2008 par exemple comme tel dit
vous pouvez négocier au niveau de
l'entreprise
le contingent d'heures supplémentaires
en toute liberté le taux de majoration
des heures supplémentaires en toute
liberté
ça c'est concret et qui plus est c'est
signe de responsabilité puisque à ce
moment-là l'accord d'entreprise prime
sur toutes les autres sources
donc nous avons déjà emprunté cette voie
il faut la parfaire alors comment la
parfaire d'abord il faut se souvenir
qu'on ne déshabille jamais paul pour
habiller pierre
ce qui vient de me chanter les derniers
convertis et je me méfie toujours des
derniers convertis ce sont les plus
excessifs et c'est pas dans l'excès
qu'on progresse ceux qui découvrent
l'accord d'entreprise alors qu'il
l'ignorait ya trois matin et qui
viennent nous dire aujourd'hui tout doit
passer par accord d'entreprise
mon voisin va vous expliquer puisqu'ils
représentent les tpe et pme que ça c'est
un leurre pourquoi parce que même avec
la bonne volonté du monde est croyez-moi
que nous essayons de convaincre les
chaînes entreprises tpe pme les
organisations syndicales de développer
dans ce pays de cultures
action collective on l'a écrit dans le
rapport combrexelle on va proposer des
formations dans les écoles de commerce
dans les universités mais bon dieu
la culture c'est pas un claquement de
doigts vous l'avez dit c'est plusieurs
années donc nous avons des situations où
nous n'arriverons pas à développer des
accords d'entreprise innovant organisant
de manière efficace et relations de
travail donc la branche a un rôle à
jouer
je pense que les branches évidemment il
faut les regrouper et nous avons
désormais les moyens de regrouper les
branches professionnelles serre que le
ministre du travail
désormais à la possibilité de regrouper
des branches c'est une question de
volonté politique est aussi est ce que
les acteurs sont prêts à le faire mais
les branches devraient réfléchir
outre la régulation de la concurrence à
créer des nouvelles garanties sociales
et algré des nouvelles garanties
sociales par branches d'activité et ça
c'est un formidable défi pour elle elle
devrait mieux accompagner quelque chose
qui est extraordinaire au 21ème siècle
le deal la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels flexisécurité c'est le
modèle vers lequel nous sommes engagés
flexi adaptabilité d'entreprise sécurité
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
bon et puis à la loi moi je ne suis pas
de ceux qui pensent que la loi doit être
un doigt sera donné à 50 principe je
fais référence ici à l' ouvrage de mon
collègue antoine lyon caen et de mon
collègue badinter
maintenant vous connaissez quand même
l'astuce avait n'ai pas vu le piège
personne n'a vu le piège enfin le piège
il est tellement visible qui vaut quand
même le dire si je mets 50 principes et
point barre vous pensez qu'avec 50
principe on peut organiser aujourd'hui
les relations de travail qui vont de
l'internet à l' usine
donc comment ne pourra pas organiser
efficacement en 50 articles 50 principe
qui va compléter le juge
voilà or là vous vous trouvez à ce
moment là avec une réglementation
jurisprudentielle trop importante trop
instable et trop compliqué à construire
non c'est pas une question de quantité
c'est une question de qualité
là où nous avons failli c'est que nous
avons dans ce code du travail
des incohérences des inutilités
nous avons des complexités nous avons
des vieilleries donc déjà on ferait un
petit travail
oh certes de bénédictin reprenez chacun
des articles et vous vous posez la
question est il utile ou non et il en
contradiction ou non avec une autre
disposition
croyez moi là vous allez faire passer la
tondeuse
mais il restera quand même des centaines
et des centaines d'articles pourquoi
parce qu'il faut se convaincre qu
organiser les relations de travail dans
la société du 21ème siècle c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que dans celle
du 20e et encore plus dans celle du 19e
en raison de l'immense diversité des
activités professionnelles pas ça le
problème
quand un chirurgien va opérer un matin
il va vous dire que c'est simple
évidemment c'est compliqué mais il va le
faire
bon le droit du travail comme toute
branche juridique comme l'économie comme
la science ça devient plus compliqué
mais c'est pas des complexités qui sont
dangereuses c'est la complexité inutile
donc la loi a un rôle à jouer
elle doit servir au fonds un peu de
voiture balai du tour de france pour
ceux qui n'excéderont pas à des accords
d'entreprise ça c'est sûr et si elle ne
le fait pas on pénalise les petites
entreprises les grandes entreprises
aujourd'hui dans ce pays
croyez moi elles ont développé un niveau
d'accord collectif de très grande
qualité avec des innovations
extraordinaire notre cible c'est pas les
grandes entreprises notre cible c les
moyennes et petites entreprises où l'on
doit développer ce dialogue social mais
tant qu'on n'y arrivera pas il faut des
dispositions relais et le législateur a
une responsabilité ensuite vous avez
raison c'est au législateur d'organiser
la façon dont la négociation collective
doit s'orchestrer au niveau des branches
et au niveau des entreprises
il doit fixer simplement des principes
alors il faut parvenir à la lecture de
la constitution puisque le terme qui
était complètement dévoyé par
l'initiateur principes fondamentaux du
droit du travail n'est plus non plus
adaptées à ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui
de législateurs 21e siècle ça c'est sûr
il peut pas se contenter de dire trois
principaux généraux non il doit dire
voilà comment s'organise tel mécanisme
dans l'entreprise mais je laisse de la
liberté le meilleur exemple pour moi
ni pas parce que je suis ici chez les
républicains mais c'est une vérité
prenez la loi de 2008 sur la durée du
travail
prenez la technique dite d'annualisation
du temps de travail
nous avons connu plusieurs systèmes
juridiques ça a commencé par des
systèmes extrêmement corsetée dire que
législateur fixe et tous les partenaires
sociaux ni violente de briser ah oui
c'est sympathique vous lui dites de
négocier enfin nous négocions quasiment
avec le menu imposé
vous appelez ça une négociation moi
j'appelle ça négociations de 357 sur la
tempe
bon et puis petit à petit du chanteur
s'est dit on va faire confiance aux
partenaires sociaux
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
dire comme la loi de 2008 chers amis
voulaient organiser le temps de travail
non pas sur la semaine mais sur un
référentiel plus important exemple sur
l'année où vous pouvez avoir à ce moment
là des semaines de travail à 39 d'autres
qui ce qu'on passe à 30 2 à la fin vous
faites le bilan si vous dépassez les 507
heures ou payseur supplémentaires si
vous dépassez pas terminus et larry
chanteur a dit mais moi je fixe juste un
cadre général et vous débrouiller donc
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut développer
c'est à dire si l'on veut donner à la
négociation collective singulièrement la
négociation collective d'entreprise
je fixe jeunes cadres parce que moi
quand même par la présence de députés et
et vous chers députés
moi quand je suis élu le social quand
même ça représente quelque chose pour
vous du jour au lendemain vous allez
dire ah ben non on fait plus rien en
matière sociale mais sûr que non mais
c'est à vous de nous dire voilà chers
amis négociateurs le cadre dans lequel
vous allez évoluer et je vous donne de
la liberté
ça s'appelle un équilibre et je pense
que si nous travaillons dans ce sens là
et maintenant le travail xaintrailles
très concret une fois qu'on a déterminé
la méthode
le plus important c'est de prendre thème
par thème et de dire nous ouvrons nous
n'ouvrons pas et c'est là où nous avons
mais je veux pas empiéter sur une table
ronde tout à l'heure c'est là où nous
commençons à voir des divergences fortes
avec l'actuel gouvernement et j'étais
membre de la commission comme rexel
donc j'ai bien vu ce qui s'était passé
puisque j'étais à matignon lors de la
remise immédiatement le premier ministre
sait pas si le pensait au fond de
lui-même il dit oh ben non on n'ouvre
pas sur le seuil de déclenchement des
heures supplémentaires nigo évident mais
c'est le dernier truc qu'il faut faire
pourquoi mais parce que
abdou négocié sur le contingent quand on
négocie sur le tout mais le troisième
élément indispensable c'est de négocier
sur le curseur qui fait déplacer alors
je sais bien qu'on touche ni dans ce
pays née au totem néo tabou il n'y a
rien du tout m'enfin à un moment donné
c'est comme le fruit croyez-moi quand on
aime ce fruit est mûr il faut le
cueillir sinon ils temps mort à tout
seul et là le fruit il est presque mûrs
donc ce que nous allons faire vous le
dis très concrètement dans les mois qui
viennent afin de préparer une alternance
positive nous allons lister très
concrètement les dispositions du code du
travail sur des thèmes comme la durée du
travail le contrat de travail la santé
au travail et bien d'autres mécanismes
et là nous allons dire là il faut ouvrir
là il faut ouvrir pour tel et tel raison
et nous allons convaincre de la
nécessité de l'ouverture
regardez le travail à temps partiel il
est inadmissible qu'on ne puisse pas
dérogé aux 24 heures par accord
d'entreprise
qu'est ce que c'est et histoire autre
exemple il est inadmissible qu'on ne
puisse pas renouvelé une période d'essai
dans une entreprise par accord
d'entreprise
il faut un accord de branche étendu mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
ça n'a pas de sens donc voyez
l'equilibre voyez que là tout le monde y
trouve son compte et ne va pas échappé
que j'étais corse
ambiance et tue c'est une rigolade pour
un compatriote aux corses quand ils
voient un professeur droite raille corse
est liée aux professeurs mais vous
plaisantez
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
mais en corse
on a une belle formule et qui résume au
fait le sens de l'action on dit il c'est
messi pau qui a les corses en un seul
ensemble on peut et c'est ensemble qu'on
réforme aura le droit du travail
c'est pas les uns contre les autres
c'est pas le législateur contre les
partenaires sociaux c'est pas la branche
contre l'entreprise
c'est chacun doit trouver sa place ça
s'appelle une architecture et une
architecture où nous sommes tous
bâtisseur vous mesurez alors l'optimisme
qui est le mien moi je suis convaincu
qu'on va y arriver et je suis convaincu
qu'on va convaincre nos compatriotes un
de la nécessité évidemment de réformer
et de la réforme et ensemble parce que
là aussi
sinon on n'arrive pas à convaincre
chacun nos compatriotes sur le terrain
de la nécessité d'évoluer nous n'y
arriverons pas mais nous allons y
arriver